jean claude carrière le plus étonnant
chez vous élection qui en parlera le
plus étonnant c'est vos origines
finalement sire que vous venez d'un
d'une famille n'est pas de livres vous
êtes le premier de la famille à avoir eu
le certificat d'études et quand vous
êtes arrivé à paris c'est pas vrai ça
que vous êtes allé au lycée val claret
des paquets volders récemment c'est
absolument faux avant et j'avais 13 ans
13 ans et demi est tout à fait à la fin
de la guerre j'avais passé la guerre à
l'abri dans un collège religieux
ouais on s'était bien gardé de me dire
que j'ai appris très vite
vous savez je crois vous avez 25 pour
mes premiers bouquins en quoi ces
lézards ou c'était avant les arts c'est
intéressant ça comment ça se passe et où
ils dansent un premier roman on se rend
compte toujours oui je prends cela 0 oui
au volant de ma campagne mais aussi dans
un veston pas regarder les autres un
film en naîtra un jour parce que j'ai
retrouvé il ya quelques années donc que
j'aime beaucoup qui robert doisneau
souvent et qui photographient la
banlieue de paris à s'était procuré un
dépôt que j'étais adolescent juste après
la guerre et il a tellement d'histoires
et moins aussi quand on se rend compte
pas ceux à se raconter sur cette période
d'un très très peu traité dans le
segment vont se retrouver avec un
bistrot apparaissent police trois
personnes à toulouse réclame en plus mon
père était cité la fin de la guerre mon
père était fatigué était malade il
n'avait pas de quoi vraiment survivre là
où ils étaient et ils sont parrains
décision que j'ai toujours eu beaucoup
de mal à comprendre décidé de changer de
vie complètement et devenir retenir
c'est que ce qui comptait c'est la fille
qui montrait des ours et tout le monde
des décalages
lorsqu'elle vivait avec un travail avec
plein de légendes urbaines mes amis qui
s'appelait d'aider la vie brisée ses
ventes
vous étiez provincial du mondial sans
jamais être vraiment parisiens n'ont
vraiment parisien je crois pas j'aime
beaucoup paris j'habite chez ma vie j'ai
toujours gardé un pied là bas quelque
part il sait qu'une grande sécurité
quand je me balade beaucoup c'est bien
connu la droite à gauche
j'aime beaucoup aller voir ce qui se
passe chez d autres dans les cultures
souvent lointaine pour essayer de voir
s'il n'y a pas chez eux une histoire qui
ne passionnerait d'entendre envie de
raconter mais j'ai toujours quelque part
un pied de la maison je suis né
d'ambiance dans l'hérault en colère midi
alors quand vous travaillez comme ça
avec un grand un grand réalisateur soit
duel à l'époque où que ce soit fort mal
en ce moment donc hoffman l'insoutenable
insoutenable à produire mes dires d'un
desertec l'insoutenable assez clair
c'est une fondation vous a vu dans le
titre ils sont mille légèreté en gros un
soutien ferme et laissez votre mari vous
partez absolument je suis toujours seule
je laisse ma femme ma fille et mes amis
hors d'eux hors de cette solitude l2 il
faut vraiment être enfermé complètement
avec le metteur en scène c'est pas le
cas de tout le monde mais moi ma règle
toujours de travailler avec le metteur
en scène puisque de toute façon à un
moment donné le film sera le sien
alors il vaut mieux qu'ils soient là dès
le début très les distractions tous les
combien pour très très peu là je sors de
trois mois avec milos forman aux états
unis enfermés dans une maison par sa
maison dans un chrono dans le
connecticut est notre seule distraction
et très une partie de billard
quotidienne est donc un petit peu de
télévision va vraiment un très peu sinon
c'est vraiment 12 13 heures de travail
assez external c'est un travail physique
il faut jouer il faut improviser il faut
15 20 25 fois de suite revenir sur la
même scène jusqu'à ce qu'elle satisfasse
les deux paires comme les personnages
qu'on voit dans les films ils ont été
joués par vous pas réalisateurs avec qui
il travaille je vous rappelle dans le
sillage des femmes de chambre le 1er mai
avec une belle frousse des jours la
femme de chambre c'est à dire il était
la femme de chambre et celle estime et
moi tous les autres personnages comme il
était très sourd je devais travailler
dans une chambre d'hôtel je devais crier
assez destine je t'aime ce jeu et il me
répondait avec cette grosse voix qui
posaient beaucoup de points
d'interrogation au voisin vous savez les
autres chansons pour n'avoir là tout de
suite des résultats de certaines lettres
chèques et la scène d'amour qu'en fait
quand les agendas le rejoindre après la
vague qui faisait
je crois que c'était kaufmann la vram
rappelé tout simplement parce que j'ai
un peu plus costaud que mais je pouvais
le prendre dans mes bras et le contraire
eût été plus difficile
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui oh la la c'est une scène par exemple
qui a été répété entre le métal est
l'auteur sait attendre
vous n'étiez pas faire un film écrire un
film avec lui dont madonna c'est là
c'est sûr la crème gel a été en rapport
avec avec madonna black angels de la
pression du roman dans blood bowl riche
mais pour des raisons deux productions
scénario a été écrit et mais
malheureusement magna n'a pas fait que
des succès aussi l'humain le court
encore après un succès et ils ont tout
simplement laissé tomber la selle à la
loi impitoyable aux états unis on n'a
pas idée et on cherche quelqu'un je
pense commencer madonna à moins que tout
simplement la tombe de projets ce qui
arrive aussi quand vous prenez un
bouquin vous en faites un film je vous
adaptez pas où par exemple d'en venir là
qu'il est le château de 9
c'est vrai que les souris razer vous
supprimez les rêves ou supprime l enfant
vous à l'écart en la mère de tirer
dedans certain nombre de choses ont
disparu d'ailleurs pratique
au même moment la mère de teresa elle
est restée longtemps même failli tourner
la scène jusqu'au jour où kaufmann mieux
qu'il y avait des problèmes avec la
comédienne qui devait jouer le rôle de
la mère m'a appelé et m'a dit oui où
les dates il en a vraiment besoin de
cette scène est tout de suite allé avec
un joli nom c'était très clair parce que
on écrit quelques fois des scènes
inspirées d'un livre pour expliquer un
personnage mais cantona coeur arrive par
exemple juliette binoche
quand elle est rentrée dans ce rôle de
thérèse à elle est arrivée avec sa mère
à elle avec tous son arrière-plan toute
sa vie et on n'avait plus besoin de ses
scènes bien pour la sécu l'acteur
apporte ce que louer son mot en sus que
le romancier a besoin de décrire car
nous n'avons là que du papier des signes
mais également lorsque vous faites avec
les liaisons dangereuses faut supprimer
qui parle beaucoup d'histoires
secondaire dans le regard de la assez
étroites même l'histoire principale mais
très ce qu'on a supprimé c'est un
certain nombre d'éléments du récit trop
de d'époque
par exemple l'idée de la gloire du
libertin c'est une chose dont on n'a pas
vraiment d'équivalent dans notre monde
aujourd'hui
enfin on vous propose d'en écrire par
mois beaucoup de plusieurs par semaine
non mais évidemment je ma peur faire
qu'un ou deux par an là par exemple
après la même légèreté là je n'ai pas du
tout de films qui vont sortir avant
avant deux ans il y aura valmont
milos forman et je travaille en ce
moment avec edouard niermans ces jeunes
metteurs en scène français que j'aime
beaucoup qui a beaucoup de talent sur
une adaptation là aussi une adaptation
et à la même époque résidence que
l'allemand d'un roman de schneider qui
s'appelle le retour casanova mais je
crois cet intégrisme ne tombera que dans
la fin de l'année où l'année prochaine
nous avons acquis petit train infernal
danser balzac non je me rends pas compte
ou non du tout non non il me semble que
j'ai pas de répondeur devenu réalité
pour moi même je suis mon corps et j'ai
pas de secrétaire non je m'en sois connu
un passé que ceux qui travaillent pas
beaucoup ces quelques fruits ce sont des
morts ou qui travaille lentement qui
perdent du temps on travaille et j'ai eu
la chance dans ma jeunesse d'apprendre à
travailler ça fait ça fait gagner un
temps fou ce en plus j'ai un certain
nombre de trucs pour gagner du temps
dans la journée dit le jeu convient pas
de voiture dents cariées
je conduis pas de voiture dans paris je
lis très peu de journaux un jeune et
très peu de journaux parce qu'il ya des
gens qui lisent la même information ou
qu'ils écoutent la radio qui la
regardent la télévision
quatre ou cinq fois par jour la neige
exactions ne s'est pas attardé point de
vue des points de vue différents
ensuite je pars jamais un week-end
pratiquement jamais en vacances et je
n'accepte pas de dîner en ville
le sous chaque soir j'en profite et je
regarde la télévision principalement
partir de 11 heures du soir ce qui me
permet d'aller au spectacle assez
souvent
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous y mettez un
pouce bleus